Another really complex technique that I believe in...
...is that you take notes as they speak.
You write down what they are saying.
Why?
What greater tribute do you pay someone to write down some of the things they say.
In other words, for all I know it's a form of immortality.
This person thinks enough of me to write down what I'm saying.
So, you write it down and then, I'll tell you another thing I do,...
...I read back to them what I've written to make sure I got it right.
In my lifetime, I have found that, rarely if ever has the other side said to me,...
..."You know, you got that right."
"That's exactly what I've said."
No.
Usually they say, "No, you left something out."
Or, "Your emphasis was wrong."
And what I do is, I don't argue with them.
I change what I've written so they agree that I've gotten down what they said.
In other words, what I'm doing is I'm beginning with agreement...
...even if what they're saying is a complaint.
In essence, I'm saying to them that "he understands what my complaint is."